well the top prosecutor in Illinois is
trying to turn the page from a dark
period in Chicago police history it's
believed that one bad cop preyed on
innocent residents of a housing project
rounding up dozens of people on bogus
charges and now efforts are underway to
exonerate them Dean Reynolds has that
story an empty lot now marks the spot of
one of the worst Chicago Police scandals
in history
once the Ida B Wells housing project it
was where a group of corrupt Chicago
cops prayed almost risk-free on
residents for most of a decade sergeant
Ronald Watts was the ringleader
residents accused him and his squad of
extortion filing false police reports
planting evidence and assault
you didn't cooperate with him he was
born down he was against he was against
his operation on his way or didn't one I
was terrified I was trying to get away
get out that neighborhood I had a what a
go Willie Martin and Cleon Glover are
two of 42 wrongly convicted people
exonerated so far by state's attorney
Kim Fox lawyers from fox's conviction
Integrity Unit are reviewing 30 to 40
additional cases connected to watts did
the people in the neighborhood you know
did they complain about this yeah
everybody spoke up a lot of people spoke
up he's a sergeant with a badge he has
his own game so who would believe us
Joshua temper of the University of
Chicago's exoneration project says the
answer until recently was no one they
let it go on because they view these
people as disposable and they didn't
care these are black people in the
housing projects who in their minds were
guilty of something and guilty of
something sergeant watts was sentenced
to 22 months for trying to steal from an
FBI informant anybody I know what he not
read you your rights and Martez wise
went to prison too because of Watts
during that time I had just have my son
I was away for number four years he
barely even knew who I was because he
was just born so I had to rebound with
him for years taken away for nothing for
CBS this morning Saturday Dean Reynolds
Chicago 42 wrongful convictions 42 there
may be another 30 or 40 more and and
there are bad cops in you know
departments across the country I've
covered them in Brooklyn you know in DC
in New Orleans and it's it's the bad
cops that give good cops a bad name
right and the idea that your voice
doesn't count that's the problem too
that these people had a voice but it was
completely discounted yeah some very
good work think I'm but a carcass
exoneration project and